une année utile une année de combat de
relance et d'ambition c'est la vision d'
emmanuel macron pour 2021
car si en 2020 le coc vite 19 a
contraint l'exécutif à mettre sur pause
de nombreuses réformes
pas question pour le chef de l'état de
renoncer à son agenda économique
mais emmanuel macron devra aussi tenir
compte des enjeux liés à la santé du
pays mise à mal par la crise sanitaire
nous avons encore pour plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois un combat
sanitaire à conduire contre l'épidémie
nous aurons aussi de combat économique
conséquence directe de la crise
sanitaire notamment pour notre jeunesse
alors que les inégalités sociales déjà
présentes vont s'accroître alors parmi
les défis qui l'attendent il ya bien
évidemment la campagne de vaccination
contre le coronavirus elle a démarré le
27 décembre dernier et se poursuivra une
bonne partie de l'année à venir
sans oublier la continuité de la gestion
de la crise sanitaire avec au menu fut
la réouverture des lieux culturels des
restaurants des bars le tout en évitant
une troisième vague et en éventuel
troisième confinement au delà du défi
sanitaire emmanuel macron va devoir
faire face au calendrier des réformes
qu'il avait initialement prévue avant
l'avènement du court aux navires us
parmi les différents dossiers quelques
ministres l'ont déjà annoncé la réforme
des retraites est l'une de leurs
priorités pour l'année 2000 21
il ne faut pas oublier la réforme des
retraites c'est une réforme qui est
importante c'est une réforme de justice
sociale il faut que cette réforme
elles puissent être menées mais il faut
le faire dans le dialogue social avec
les partenaires sociaux
quand on aura pu surmonter l'urgence du
moment ça fait partie de notre agenda
social pour 2021
une réforme qui a provoqué de nombreux
appels à manifester l'année dernière et
qui pour certains dans l'opposition ou
dans les syndicats est aujourd'hui loin
d'être une priorité
les français n'en veulent pas et même le
medef sur le fond plutôt favorables à la
réforme juge préférable d'attendre une
relance de l'économie
engager une réforme si effectivement on
a une économie qui est par terre parce
que l'épidémie dur parce qu'on n'arrive
pas à repartir
il ne faut pas ajouter une réforme
compliquée à une situation économique
difficile
il ya trop de tensions sociales dans ce
pays ma conviction profonde c'est qu'il
n'y aura pas de réforme des retraites
sur ce quinquennat s'ajoute à l'agenda
de 2021 la loi sécurité globale avec
déjà des appels à manifester contre ce
projet à l'e3 16 et 30 janvier prochains
la loi bioéthique de son côté sera
examiné au sénat le 19 janvier prochain
sur l'adoption ne devrait pas avoir lieu
avant l'été 2021
autres sujets au menu le climat avec ce
référendum voulu par emmanuel macron
pour introduire la protection de
l'environnement dans la constitution
pour certains défenseurs de
l'environnement cette initiative vient
masquer un profond désaccord entre les
objectifs de l'exécutif et les
conclusions de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat de nombreux chantiers et
défis pour le chef de l'état qui risque
de devoir se livrer à un numéro
d'équilibriste en 2021
l'agenda des six premiers mois de
l'année à venir devrait être détaillée
lors d'un séminaire gouvernemental
coup d'envoi le 13 janvier prochain